you know there's two types of fans
that are very similar in two different
aspects of life tupac rap fans
and little wayne rap fans i'll put those
in the same category because little
wayne
fans are [ __ ] crazy because they
think he's he's the second most
overrated rapper but nonetheless
um tupac fans i got rested soul kobe
fans
right if you talk to a kobe fan they
think kobe's like
one or two all time he's two you're
crazy
you're crazy he's two to me
if you if someone asks you who's the
greatest nba player ever and you say
any other names besides michael jordan
or lebron james
you're just heavily biased and you grew
up like i mean will chamberlain did a
lot of [ __ ]
yeah but he was playing against
[ __ ] that look like me
i say that same i say this come on story
but but there was just a bunch of
[ __ ] balding white dudes out there
bro
listen to this all right so this is
where i'm at with it
we're talking about we talk we talking
about rings right now this is what i'm
gonna say right
lebron this year is his tenth time going
to the league i mean going to the going
to the championship right
oh i can't wait for i can't wait for
this argument you're about to make it if
he's
[ __ ] if he
wins every time this man has
10 championship rings bill russell did
that yeah
and that against guys that look like me
in this era
lebron had the chance to do that are you
about to get in lebron's ass right now
pause
what i'm going to say is after he if he
plays these couple years and makes a run
of three rings and gets past the five
that kobe has
on the stat board on the rings on
everything he's gonna be past
kobe so so can i point something out
because i think lebron gets a really bad
uh
rap for the how many times he's been to
the finals versus how many times he's
won a ring
like we don't talk about jordan or
kobe we don't talk about the year
kobe was on the lakers before they jerry
west handed him paul gasol for nothing
and they were a [ __ ] eight seed
getting bounced out
trust me the suns did it yeah but it's
the number but what i'm saying
is the years that kobe didn't make the
finals
the years jordan did yeah lebron's going
to the finals
like his failure years are like you know
what he made it to the finals
but he's going to the finals and losing
hey
would you so jordan went to the finals
and never lost but
but what's okay a normal year for lebron
is making it to the finals right
a normal year for any uh jordan went to
the final six times how many years did
he play 12 years 13 years yeah
so that means half of his career he
didn't go to the finals yeah
but when he went what did he do so is it
better if lebron had just gotten bounced
in the in the eastern conference finals
those years instead of going and losing
yeah i mean no no no no no no look the
level would have still been the same
they still would have been saying he
lost
so why don't they say that when kobe was
getting [ __ ] held skied up when he
had no help
because when he goes to the finals he
wins so
that's not true lebron not going how
many times did kobe lose in the finals
he lost
the celtics once but guess what guess
what
the bronze other years lebron is year 17
he's made it to the finals 10
10 10 years so over half of his career
he's been in the finals
right he's probably going to go another
at least one time with the lakers
because charles barkley hates sitting up
on that charles barkley's a [ __ ]
and i don't hate sitting up on that
panel with shaq bro because he don't
have no chips
that's fine but lebron's got chips yeah
but he broke lebron james he loses
one ring he's about to win a ring with
his third team he loses in the chip
he okay so this is where
you have no argument here let's look at
who lebron's competition has been in the
finals all right the only one i'll give
you
there's only one ring that he lost that
was unexcusable and i was against the
mavs in
2011. that was a joke
that's his black eye on his career is
that one series
outside of that the nba is
crazier than ever jordan couldn't get
out of the east in the 80s
because of detroit the sixers the
celtics
right figured it out by the way by the
way
you watch the last dance and and they're
like
yo jordan was facing a feisty
cavaliers team and who were the best
players on the cavaliers mark
price and [ __ ] or no yeah craig hilo
mark price and [ __ ]
brad daughtry and jordan had hard times
getting past them
nonetheless that was the year of the i
think the
white hoop dude was nice as hell all
right
listen listen listen lebron is no
like nobody's ever [ __ ] faced tougher
competition in the finals
that's a fact this man went against peak
spurs before kauai
right as a kid with nobody he had daniel
marshall eric snow was his starting
point guard and they had big z
this was before mo williams was even on
the team they went to the finals
obviously he got smashed by the [ __ ]
spurs because we're talking peak spurs
right this is
[ __ ] duncan duncan ginobili tony
parker in
in their [ __ ] greatest he had to play
the mavs which they should have won no
[ __ ]
then they play the thunder with three
future
nba mvps on the roster they had james
harden kevin durant and russell
westbrook all on the same [ __ ] team
lebron made light work of them year two
then the next two years
it's battles with the spurs this is new
peak spurs
with [ __ ] kawhi leonard and he splits
it 50 50. they get one they get a wing
run here
kawhi wasn't averaging 20. but he was
locking
[ __ ] to [ __ ] down he was bruce
berwick
no he wasn't come on he won he won a a
finals mvp
the you're the second one yeah but i'm
saying yeah all right i'll give him
so he played played in it twice so then
he has to go
against the [ __ ] warriors bro who's
legitimately the greatest team i've ever
i think ever
if you were to just put like talent
you throw the warriors with katie steph
and clay on the [ __ ] against anybody
like yeah so he has to play them four
years in a row
year one kyrie and kevin love are
injured
matthew dellavedova is his [ __ ]
started point guard he's got [ __ ]
uh mozgov got all this [ __ ] you to give
him to even now what do you mean to hold
him up
he took the [ __ ] he took he took the
cavaliers to six or he took the warriors
to six they
they should have won the series and they
did
then the next year they win
greatest [ __ ] ring ever won down 3-1
lebron wins the greatest ring anyone's
ever won
and then and then the next two years
they just run into the buzzsaw of like
bro it's kevin durant and the and the
warriors
it wasn't fair they ruined the nba but i
say all that to say lebron has had the
toughest competition
and he's about to win his third ring
he's he's better than kobe
he's better than kobe of course you're
crazy
kobe's like top seven player of all time
he's certainly not top so eminem is top
three rappers
top five for you that's what it sounds
like like it's like
like there's no way it's like not look
wait wait
are you comparing eminem look lebron is
is jay-z
not eminem come on man lebron is jay-z
yes
and jordan is rock him bro
number two is he's not lebron is number
two bro
kobe should look like a number two yes
he is you're crazy
kobe is number two though can we pull up
what year seven can we fill up with year
number 17
look like for kobe versus what it looked
like for lebron
actually let's look at my phone
kobe bryant is for sure different
well it's just not even close year 17
lebron did you see lebron james to score
38 points 16 rebounds and 10 assists in
an elimination game in the western
conference
i don't know if you saw that he's he's
35 years old you're 17. i know this is a
different type of animal and he's about
he's a different type of animal you i
mean you put in no you're right
four to five million dollars in your
body at this point closing them kobe
wasn't not doing that so we told you did
a lot of that since you give
no kobe head you know one big thing is
with kobe gonna get that surgery
overseas that's what people know people
don't know that
he was if he was work it's out there
that lebron
puts four five six seven million dollars
in his body
as far as training and doing all of that
[ __ ] you know why but it's like
it's like the greatest of all time but
think about it it's like the rappers not
having
twitter and instagram and youtube at the
time and then
one of the then lebron comes along and
he got twitter and youtube and instagram
and now
i don't think it's the same thing it is
shout out to lebron though yeah sure
he's yeah shout out to lebron he's
number three so um my favorite player is
carmelo by the way
really yes oh you're one of those guys
of all time
i mean i respect it that's a risk that's
an original scottie
you used to be scottie pippen carmelo
was a
fun to watch they should have did
something with the [ __ ] when they had
ai that would have been crazy
yeah i'd like that squad